Hector from a psychological point of
view how would you stay focused when
you're having good results instead of
being to confidence Hector you're
speaking to a what I'd like to consider
myself a confident sales guy and I
thought you were going to ask how do you
stay confident when you're not getting
good results which is probably the
harder thing I suppose the curveballs
there I like it Hector uh I tried it
everything I do Hector me personally I I
keep myself to a 30 day cycle that might
be coming back to having you know ten
plus your sales career which I'm quite
sure it probably does but I want to be
certain that I have a call a pipeline or
call it a roadmap or forecast but I want
to make sure that i'm always when that
deal closes or partnership closes
whatever it might be that there's
something coming next and what that
looks like so you really have to just
build your own internal pipeline in and
stay committed to that because it is
easy to get caught up in the winds and
say oh I you know it's the fifth of the
month that i'm already looking great or
whatever your case scenario might be you
really have to think long term and think
ahead that's that's the thing that kind
of just drives me and keeps me focused
and what what is it for you you think I
like having people in my network who can
kick my ass you know keep my head in
check um because a lot of pouches going
really well for me like the YouTube
channels exploding got a book deal lots
of great things but you know I have a
mastermind group of other entrepreneurs
and we meet every month and and I'll
I'll say how well everything's going and
you're like well how can it be better
than that you know why aren't you here
right what's your stretch little great
that you hit your goal but what's the
stretch goal how do you get there and
it's kind of challenging me to do more I
have an agent who helps me with my
videos and helps me become a better
speaker and every week he looks at my
videos and sends me feedback and tells
me all the things that need to be fixed
and worked on so you know I think wow I
was a great video he'll give me like the
10 things that were wrong and I
to get you up right pocket and I
appreciate that so you have people in
your network I think who can kick your
ass and give you you bring you back down
to reality who encouraged you who don't
say you suck you know but who can can
make you see that you could be much
bigger than you are where I think a lot
of entrepreneurs they there they're the
you know they've done the most in their
environment you never want to be that
person you want to have people around
you who encouraged you to be more and
who see a bigger future for you then
then you might even see for yourself I'm
super helpful yeah and that you know for
for myself I always keep an eye on the
competition too and you know just being
able to to gauge what they're doing how
they're doing that really drives me as
well because if if they're doing
something well well you know I want to
make damn sure that I'm doing that even
better but by this time next month